this episode had plenty of make outs and
a couple fake out so let's discuss it
all on Sweetwater secrets hey river
babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 312 chapter 47 bizarro Dale
which actually wasn't that bizarre at
all in fact this is now my favorite
episode of the season what seriously
today I'm so thrilled to show you a long
chat with star Vanessa Morgan talking
all about Shoney's evolution in this
episode the introduction of the new girl
gang coming to town and your exclusive
first look at their new jackets a first
look plus I've also got a fun new nugget
from Ashlee Marie and of course my
hisses and kisses so get pumped but in
an amazing twist most of this week's
Riverdale storylines were connected to
the couples on our show so 7 seconds in
heaven is going to be more like 7
minutes in heaven which means I'm going
to keep things oh so brief in the blue
and gold breakdown first things first
after destroying all the fizzle rocks
Hermione decided that Veronica and
Reggie's punishment is finding a way to
repay her unknown buyer so they decided
to team up for a little highway heist
you can be my baby driver
just please don't scratch my car despite
getting shot in the process and
receiving an inky surprise Reggie
successfully robbed his dad's car
dealership and he and Veronica set out
to meet Hermione's mysterious new
partner three march in angels yes it
turns out that gladys is back in town
and she's looking to take control as a
new crime queen oh and also Reggie's car
please
mrs. Jones Reggie loves that car and
I'll make sure I take real good care of
her with Gladys and jellybean back in
town it seems like the Jones family was
finally getting back to a good place but
this is Riverdale think again got dad
wrapped around my pinkie near this
weakness baby meanwhile with Tom Keller
and Sierra McCoy's wedding just days
away the parents of Riverdale received
cryptic messages from a gargoyle King
and they were told they needed to
reunite the midnight club and complete
ascension Knight
where your children will pay the price
but it turns out it was all just a big
distraction to keep the parents occupied
while The Gargoyle gang invaded the
sexytime bunker in teen napped Kevin and
moose after their first night of
lovemaking just as Megan was being
forced to flip for their fate their
parents and Cheryl of Riverdale rescued
the two boys and revealed the newest
gargoyle King to be mooses dad but once
again this was just a frustrating
fake-out
tomboy was using the costume to sell
drugs but major Mason was using it to
what scare his kid
I don't know Jughead but I do know that
it's time to switch over to all the
romance fuelled storylines with our
super special extended version of seven
seconds in heaven first up let's just
take a second to highlight that this was
our sexiest episode of Riverdale ever
when the parents were calling each of
their kids to make sure that they were
safe they were all half naked and
sharing some serious smooches bug head
check veggie you betcha show knee hell
yes even Kevin and moose took things to
the next level this week I just hope
they took Cheryl's advice first so I
bring her fresh set of sheets if I were
you a lot of people have had sex on that
cot and while the couple's of Riverdale
work noodling including Tom and Sierra
which I really didn't want to see Josie
and Sweet Pea were finally addressing
their summer fling and breaking things
off for good does it have to be so
official as the stresses of Josie's
Juilliard audition caused her to reach
her breaking point it was Archie's turn
to be there for her and even though the
star did not receive a callback she did
give us some sweet season 1 flashbacks
during an adorable duet with Archie and
it seems that their musical chemistry
has finally transformed into sexual
chemistry ok alright ok I'm here for the
snout but exciting chipper squeals aside
the couple that was challenged the most
in this week's episode was definitely
show knee in an attempt to help Kevin
convince moose to be out and proud with
his father Cheryl took things a step too
far during her morning announcements
ascertain oh so honky all-american our
ROTC cadet is afraid to come out of the
closet
needless to say show knee was all kinds
of pissed that Cheryl would drop such a
big bombshell to the entire
school oh my god is this our first fight
sure I'll get some perspective did you
know that my uncle hated the fact that I
dated girls that's why the Serpent's
were so important to me Cheryl then made
it her mission to make things right so
she apologized to moose gave Tony her
admissions interview slot at a very
esteemed college and most importantly
gathered up a new girl gang for Tony to
rule I thought maybe we could start a
new dime to see more of course you are
so take a look at what Vanessa Morgan
told me when I asked her to spill all
the behind-the-scenes secrets about
Shoney's evolution in this episode and
the inside scoop about the pretty
poisons what has been your favorite
Shoni scene to film what season three
all my favorite Shoni scenes of season
three are in episode 12 we have some
cute bed moments and we kiss a lot more
and episode 12 where it just feels more
like we're like connected and close and
a couple and we get in a fight for the
first time and it just shows ups and
downs and then dynamics and trying to
overcome that and it was kind of
interesting getting mad at her I've had
to do a scene where I was like
full-blown you know yelling at her I
think my favorite moment is when I come
into the classroom and Sheryl seeds that
I've given up a part of my life for her
the Serpent's which is like what I live
for and I walk in and she's created a
girl game for me that's my favorite show
any scene so far
talk to me about this girl gang the girl
gang so we are the pretty poisons pretty
by date poison by name for you know
obviously this new gang starting up I'm
wearing my jacket right now
yeah we're six strong girls who needed
that support system and that family and
you know Tony is excited about having
something that she's in charge of no
one's I'm excited about it me about this
jacket though this is the jacket its
purpose so I've requested to have purple
in my hair which is something I've
wanted to do since you know season two
so we're gonna put purple throughout and
this is the O first look pretty poisons
all right I'm gonna put you over in this
way that's so neat yes Cheryl this is
the most badass
a romantic thing you've ever done did
you have any input on what you want I
didn't have any of it but I think the
writer I mean me personally if I were to
make it it would have done it like just
the skull I think what they're trying to
do is incorporating Cheryl and Tony so
you have the lips and then this ball so
I think it was supposed to be like a
combo because she started it for her and
then she you know took over so yeah I
think it's like a combination of us
together now I'll be bringing you a lot
more information about this girl gang
including how it'll affect the Serpent's
in future episodes of Sweetwater so stay
tuned for that but for now let's unleash
my rants and raves about episode three
12 in hisses and kisses kicking things
off
I'm sending mini hisses to Cheryl for
taking things too far and her not so
blind item about moose she did apologize
though and it was great to see Tony step
up and put her babe back in place she'll
stop and listen to me but now I'm
sending massive hisses - Penelope
blossom because her blatant homophobia
is absolutely disgusting it burns me
that there are people in this town that
still believe that being gay is anything
less than rapturous love is love and
it's beautiful in every single form get
it got it good
next up hisses to the fact that just as
I was really starting to like moose he
announced that he needed to leave town
moving to Glendale stay with my aunt
wait hold up did you say Glendale not
Greendale okay look I completely
understand why moose feels like he needs
to get out of town his dad's past demons
from the gay conversion therapy program
at the sisters of quiet mercy caused him
to snap and impersonate a twig a monster
actually you know what you do you moose
you've been through a lot so however you
need to heal I support that I just hate
seeing Kevin so sad I'm gonna miss you
Marmaduke hisses - Gladys and jelly
beans hidden intentions and they're
moved back to town I'm not sure what you
ladies are up to but please just don't
hurt the Jones boys they've been through
enough
we keep taking down gargoyle kings and
they keep popping up again it's like
playing whack-a-mole oh and hisses - yet
another fake gargoyle King reveal I
can't anymore I can't
hisses to Juilliard for denying Josie a
callback and double hisses to the fact
that we didn't get to see her audition
song I sing my heart out or a super-fun
Labonte wedding reception for Tom and
Sierra they said it didn't feel right
having a party after everything in fact
Ashley Marie was a bit peeved about that
too so take a look at what she told me
let's talk about the wedding yeah the
wedding it was a crazy time you know
Kevin kind of got unexpectedly pulled
into some madness at the same time that
Josie was auditioning for Juilliard and
even though we wanted it to be this big
you know momentous occasion and ended up
crumbling as everything does in
Riverdale and they just kept it cute and
small and sweet yeah just now the
parents wanted it like okay yeah just
mad basic so rude I'm sorry nice but at
the same time like I wanted like the big
reception to see Josie sing on it like
everything we wanted that like wanted it
right
busy cuts back together for this special
one night only a wedding Oh God can you
imagine if that actually did happen and
we sang one night only that would be
great oh my god yeah switching over to
kisses that one is going to all the
sultry scenes that we were treated to in
this week's episode especially all the
Megan smooches kiss it's Cheryl and Tony
for evolving as a couple to bug-head for
showing us and they still got it and a
veggie for kicking things up a notch and
I was pleasantly surprised by how much I
adore Josie and Archie's Sunkist first
kiss it was pretty now the only thing
that was missing from this episode was a
kiss between FP and Alison if I don't
get one soon I will scream oh absolutely
but most importantly kisses to Riverdale
for finally giving us an episode that
felt like a perfect blend of everything
that we love about the show there was
mystery intrigue car scenes new twists
fun turns and yes plenty of outrageous
moments that didn't quite make sense but
that's why I love the show and I love
you river babes for tuning in each week
with me to Sweetwater secrets now check
back with me next week for our
live preview show for episode 313
chapter 48 rec room for a welter white
weight I don't know it's really annoying
to say not my favorite episode title but
I'll have exclusive scoop straight from
Cole Sprouse about our Jones family
reunion and why bug head is doing so
well together this season so get excited
for that but for now please give this
video a like hit subscribe so you never
miss an episode then drive on down to
the comments and tell me your top hisses
and kisses of the episode which couple
had you the most hot and bothered this
week what do you think of the new pretty
poison's jacket and why do you think
Gladys was hiding secrets tell me
everything and I'm setting massive
kisses to you lovely babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]